how about three I like three
three's good well
hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Dead Space we just
killed a big old thing now we're gonna
go kill a big old other thing and maybe
a few other smaller things as we just go
on a rampage of death and destruction I
don't know can you kill
something that's already dead can the
Necromorphs even be qualified as alive
oh mining deck well am I is it time to
go to the mining deck just yet was there
something else that I could do
beforehand yeah I mean whatever I'll go
to the mining deck who knows maybe I'll
be able to get there in time to save
somebody
because it turns out I saved someone
here so why not right oh
I was too late I can't save you yeah I'm
sorry no personal ease
yay money you're not determined
clearance level Master security override
required I don't even know what that
means or how I would get that and
whatever
whoa let's miss that okay so mining a
mining
sure thing
I gotcha
I'm low on health aren't I what do I
have I didn't even pop in the store oh
no I'm fine I got plenty of goodies
all right where am I
that was a weird squonk okay hello
well that would get me back there
accessible thank you for your patience
you're welcome okay so I gotta go over
that way
any goodies down there
any goodies anywhere
any big old goodies no okay sure
whatever
I guess I just don't deserve them
guess I'm not cool enough three three
the mining duck systems are running
Haywire
great let me work on the elevators
any idea where Temple's SOS Beacon might
be
I'll check the money control room the
longitude's there we can send out a
beacon easy anyone there Hammond where
are you in defense hoping they don't
hear me
yeah those things are everywhere
no the unitologist they're all here on
the crew deck they've lost it one of
them stabbed her friend in the head he
just stood there he [__] smiled
they're going somewhere Hammond
lost a signal again we gotta find that
Beacon Isaac fast
yeah we yeah we should uh I didn't know
that there were so many survivors around
her hey node a good thing I check around
every corner right guys
well thank you for that
um also what's with the big boxes so you
want me to go there wait
no no you want me to go there what's
over here
interesting
ah okay hello oh hey what the heck are
you doing
thank you
why you need to do that why do you
always feel the need to do that
security lockdown
the miners locked up some nice gear
too bad I could have put it to work you
still could we find the right Red Coats
the captain's rig won't get me in no
that lockdown's a custom job but I can
use the captain's codes to create an
override framework
three you find a senior officers Rick
you're more like that and we're in
business I did okay framework's done
find the rigs download their codes into
a bridge console and it'll build you a
master security override
[Music]
find hanger overseer vocals rig find
first officer White's rig
find com officer Bailey's rig uh tram
supervisor Benson's foreign
hey whoa hey whoa why you be wait a
minute who said I'm not authorized who
the hell
said I'm not authorized no access I need
I need a lot holy crap okay so chief
engineer Rousseau's mining supervisor
Dallas and then Lieutenant Commander
Holtz rig
last location in Hydroponics I was in
Hydroponics somewhere in engineering
mining deck okay well I can't even get
to these so I might as well since I'm at
mining I might as well stick to Mining
and go down there and find it
um considering I
don't have access to the other one so
it's I saw that
what was oh it was Sparks and I thought
it was drippy
I thought it was some goopy drippiness
apparently not
hmm
all right bench
big lifty things why is there anything
behind there there is
God damn
come on no well I guess good that I did
the health but I didn't want to
someone's screaming
which means that some people are still
alive which is a shock
that much of a shock
because in all honesty there have been
like
there's been like very little time
from the moment that we arrived on the
station to like the last recorded
messages that I've been seeing like I
really do imagine that the it was only a
matter of like 30 minutes maybe an hour
between the differences
you don't need this
don't need this
um
finally have some contact ammo which is
good I like having that
do I want to consider using any of these
no I don't really I have a good amount
of stuff
how much ammo I got
um I could do with some more let me do
this first
yeah
and then we do
I'll do two more why not
I still have 27 I can have seven nodes
I'm so noted up all right then bench
then I can get some more upgrades and
then I'll be in good shape I could do
more contact beam oh yeah because I
didn't get this
uh increases size I like that nice and
then secondary damage over here
there we go 700 points and a big old
bullet
that's what I like to see I don't think
there's anything here really that I need
reload's already fast I got as much
damage and I don't need any more
capacity what about yeah since I do do
the pulse rifle I could do this
increase the rate of fire
ammunition capacity honestly I might as
well just go for the damage uh rate of
fire is damaged but per bullet damage is
what I'm worried about uh let's go for
the damage
okay that's better I feel good about
that
I feel real good about that
all right I like saving okay I shopped I
healed I upgraded I got everything I
need I got some extra ammo I should be
good to go
let's do this two of the mining subjects
are locked down even though all systems
are running
I'm going to figure this out
down as in I can't go to them
because it seems like I might oh
seems like I might be able to go to them
but I'm not a herbs insurer don't ask me
why but I already got this really funny
feeling about this whole endeavor
no I'm already malfunction please stand
by oh
oh
[Applause]
boy oh
hey what's up
hey whoa
oh
oh my God oh my God oh my God that's not
what I this is just a torso where's the
blade there it is
[Applause]
oh good thing that actually killed you
got a blade this is not a blade
there
no
you think that it would prioritize this
okay you're fine
ah that does look locked down
that looks excessively locked down
okay oh well well I wasn't even looking
the right direction but yeah you're
right it is locked down
so uh you write
you right
you're very right about that
all right gang
all right dudes let's see let's see
let's see
[Music]
um
oh okay
sure
sure thing humans stay out beware traps
ahead
oh
I can't read that
what
why why the screaming
take this with me why is it screaming
why
traps ahead turn back I mean I kind of
gotta
it's a good good whoa die oh I see
what's going on here
um
he
okay that looks bad uh
can I take this oh cool uh uh all right
yeah another one of those uh shove one
okay what about this
there we go
I seem to do the trick
oh
okay
come here you give me your goodies
uh
well you missed
what did you miss
oh why is it it's it's angry can you uh
check that out for me it's really angry
uh what
how did it disappear
huh
oh it's just some kind of mining cutting
thing I think I can still hear it why
can I still hear it
please don't be invisible and still here
God I really hope you're not just
invisible and still here
okay
look I don't know why logically it would
have made sense that it was invisible
and still there but trust me that's what
I thought okay
hmm
so the miners are some tough sons of
[__] that's for sure
I think they probably ended up putting
the best fight given the tools that they
have and given how effective
the slicing and dicing of what I got is
wow what happened
nope not what I meant thank you
good money
ah I see
Hello message security request retrieved
standby what do you mean stand by we got
some free called Harris stealing from
ore storage Dr Mercer sent me for Osman
work yeah I don't care if God Almighty
can you skim from cec's profit margin we
get screwed
God
so you can put that osmium down
I worked with people like you on ages
seven
they'd steal my power nose
leave me to dick with no
no let me abandon you in the dark it's
not empty
the marker whispered its Revelations
there
now I understand them
you wanna hear morning I'll change
personality not used
no no stop it please I said please when
they shut me
screamed it too I promise I will laugh
like they did
Warriors
incident report filed to bridge by Dr
Nicole Brennan see related rig activity
what that was a mission oh so so those
things aren't exactly safe I always
wondered about the Sue kiosks
I always wondered
seems like they uh
were terrible find report on the bridge
about what Harris did in ore storage how
is she involved yeah I'll I'll get to
the bridge later I guess the reason that
it wanted me to listen to that was
because that story was important
turns out it was an objective and I
never knew all along
okay
all right gang
all right
extraction area you say well beware of
traps
I have a med kit your rig looks fine so
I'm assuming you're gonna be a okay
right buddy oh
[Music]
unfortunately I have to take this not
personally
sorry
he was just he just passed out and I
just
I just stumped the crap out of him let
me sell I got a super Ruby conductor or
whatever have you la la just doing some
shopping after stomping on a corpse
who's there
oh I see you oh why yeah you get you lay
off oh
maybe not
uh-huh anything else I can Chuck at you
take this corpse
take this
take that oh you're dead never mind I
actually got something that could be
useful nope
no second chances for you all right cool
I like saving and I could buy some more
nodes that's so much money
or ammo you know I could focus on the
ammo
uh elevator
that way so I go this way
bench hello
text log says secured the subject
perimeter IEDs plasma cutter strip wire
survey Chargers three injured and
Lincoln is out of action her medications
run out rest of the supplies are holding
so far ammo food water and Thruster fuel
even without the stuff for the SOS
Beacon wired external access all the
mining bays are online now Lincoln
unconscious with nothing we can do it
broke through the floor vent one of
those flying [__] went right for
Lincoln's body and then we were fighting
six instead of five cut them up and then
shipped it all down to the smelters for
a quick cremation can't take any risks
survey charge went off too soon lost
Schlegel Fike and ziddle never seen the
inside of a head before took them to the
smelter to be cremated than its Supply
inventory can't sleep too dangerous here
took some gear to Hole up somewhere
safer McSweeney followed me yelling
about being selfish me he was the one
leading those things right to me fixed
McSweeney visited smelter can't sleep
can't sleep cold can hear all the others
yelling they're gonna get me killed
Lincoln's right I need peace and quiet
and the smelters need fuel
interesting okay
so I gotta go this way huh oh wait
battery
that's helpful
okay
good what is going on oh that's so
pretty
wow look at that
that's a thing of beauty
a piece
sure well whoa no no no no no no no no
I knew it you shouldn't be playing the
violin
that was your first mistake
you horrible Little Things
little terrible head crabs oh wait I
can't even go here
oh well I wasn't supposed to go there
I don't trust that
no personal ease
why why why why why why why oh oh
ah
oh cool
that's real nice
that's really nice
all right what do we have some moolah
not much Moolah some stasis that doesn't
bode well some big Moolah nope sorry
sorry
what do we have Planet crack of Ages 7
was conducted today everything went
smoothly from our end there seemed to
have been problems PlanetSide and we've
temporarily lost contact with Colony but
the tethers are stable with torque well
with inacceptable parameters first rock
ball was extracted from the tectonic
load approximately one hour after Planet
crack it has been process refined and
smelted for sampling results exceeded
even optimistic's initial estimates
normal recovery is around 35 mineral
five fossil 60 waste but the material
from the first ball was 65 mineral and
zero fossil in line with expectations
that's 6.5 tons of ore from a 10 ton
ball full production is now in progress
focusing on eql5 assuming it's not an
anomaly we've hit the motherload well
damn that all sounds super wonderful
super cool
man they're gonna have to give me level
three soon okay ah here we go so
speaking if well that's as expected
for authorization okay good good enough
finally getting somewhere with the
mining duck systems yeah
no and the longitudes are sealed
I need a deck administrator's trick to
get them open the duck admin is
supervisor Dallas he's on the processing
subject I've got rig activity for a
Jacob Temple 2 maintenance stuff deck
maybe he left the SOS Beacon there just
hoping to reach it through these
malfunctions no malfunctions
traps
the miner's way of holding the line [__]
okay I'll unlock the subjects just make
sure that Beacon's not wired to anything
okay I'll make sure are you serious
nothing's gonna jump out of me
I was pretty sure
oh I knew it give me your arm
oh I could oh oh give there we go
oh you still alive take this
take whoa boy uh this all right there we
go
whoa what wait who did that
oh
hey hey hey
what's the deal
what's the deal with all that
what's the deal with the nonsense
well that was weird
not sure what that was about but I'm
alive
that's all that matters all right
okay
find the admins rig
you what
you a ghost
hope not
hmm
okay
extractionary oh hi
did not see that oh hey what's up bud
where are you going
so far so good
okay
well that was fun
slightly stressful processing
got it
and there's something about a
maintenance I think Jacob Jacob Temple
was down below but I'll just follow the
Waypoint for now
hmm good
oh what is that a alien butthole what am
I looking at what's obscuring my view
right now what is this what is this
delightfulness great oh good more
ah
oh that's lovely
okay we're on lockdown
hello
okay
that's always good
okay oh
Liz it's Jacob um
Richie
if you find this I'm off deck but I'll
be right back I got a call from another
Survivor it sounded terrifying I'm gonna
lock up the SOS so you can go and get
him best launch Windows not for a while
anyway and he sounds like he's worth the
risk it's a doctor uh Mercer I think
about time
we caught a [__] break
I love you
please be careful down here
well that doesn't bode well um Mercer
did you say well that's not good well
oh well
I'm sure he's fine Dr Mercer seems like
a really nice lovely dude
everyone loves Mercer oh
okay
uh-huh
so Temple's not even on this place
wait I thought I thought it was rig
activity that said he was down below
Maybe
what's up
give me your arm
uh do I have anything big and heavy to
throw at you
how about this oh boy wait wait wait
wait wait wait too close
get out of my way
oh God oh my God oh God oh God
no no no no
all right that's what I thought
okay well this was the bad way to go
only led to a lot more problems than the
other way but I'm alive
as usual
can't see anything down here
wait are those stasis tubes oh cool
hello well behind me whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa
take your arm that's what you get
oh you sneaky oh you very sneaky hello I
was up goodbye
very dramatic
very excessively dramatic
what's going on over here
what was that
oh hey what's up
take this oh boy
well I wasted a lot of ammo
I like saving
it's a very different
Vibe down here
charity request retrieved
the majority
get back I know how to use it
you'll live for the rest of his life if
you give me Customs why the hell would
we have codes for cargo I must get to
the marker we're running out of time
give me those toes Christ this is what
you did to the captain no no Ben was an
accident don't you dare compare me to
someone like Mercer I'm trying to save
you the markers are only hope no let him
go his arms where the [__] is security
yeah I think security is far past at
this point
all right
cool
no hey what's up hi there
whoa hey what's up
you leap sploded at me
man it's dork oh did I just accidentally
use my big oh
oh you're not dead
take that all right
[Music]
okay good
okay
no I didn't use my big one okay so I'm
still all right I'm good on ammo doing
good on ammo across the board I'm being
a little bit more resourceful with it
which is nice
oh boy that's probably zero g
no personalities
[Music]
okay so there's some goodies over there
a big old rock right there I can't get
in there all right
the control room door can't open till
gravity is restored but the system won't
reset the gravity while there's loose
debris at least the processing Beam
still running stand by
oh easy
cool good very cool very good
anomalies three wow that's helpful
I imagine that if I touch the the beami
would be extremely bad for me
oh baby
hey wait a minute yes hey well
nice
whoa whoa
oh hey bud whoa where are you going
uh hold still
hold still
whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa baby where are you guys are
there
hi baby
thank you okay easy enough so there's
two more anomalies somewhere I think
that I would see them they're big rocks
unless we're talking about this
I don't think that's an anomaly where's
this nominally
we're this om namely go
where'd you put the monomaly
anybody see a mom anomaly oh Monopoly
thank you
what about another mob oh there it is
how did you hide from me
but would I want that is that what I
really want
that's the question I have right now
but what about this in way
oh
but but but fine
oh there's whoa hey um um
oh God you should have reloaded didn't
reload
well I should have used that oh hold on
hold on wow you're fast
oh wait wait should he use that but I
didn't
oh my God can you guys stop oh my God oh
God reload reload damn it oh my God hey
hey hey
[Music]
okay party over we all done
oh he's done
foreign
I know they already gooshed out all
their goodies but I just wanted to Goose
them a little more ah
oh more good
give me that
take that and I'm gonna stomp you oh God
wait
yeah
that's how I feel about that
oh
all right
hello
hello how we doing here gang
what is up
oh Dallas is rig oh there he is hey
well that's good
supervisor Dallas
final log
I've made sure they can't leave this
subject
neither can I
see what they do
the bodies
what they become
and I cannot let that happen
to me
at least if I don't have any limbs
I can't kill anyone when I'm infected
please
tell Dawn
and the kids
that I love them
oh God that was some timing
oh oh my God oh my God oh my God
oh my God oh my God oh my God oh my God
oh my God
[Music]
oh okay there it is
one more
come on man just one more
[Music]
ding what a lovely sound after that
lovely lovely audio log great
great stuff thanks Dallas oh man I'm not
gonna
nightmares about that location you've
got it I got it I'll check the
maintenance subject
uh but first i'm gonna go check out this
level three access point
and that's gonna be super cool because
now I can open all the goodies
yay
yay okay not a whole lot of stuff in
here
but enough stuff enough stuff to make it
worth it
quick stop the shop
might need more ammo after that last of
bullets ah I got a conductor I'm
actually getting pretty full here don't
need that
um I don't really need up
large it's worth so much money and I've
been doing so good I don't think I ever
need to carry more than three Med packs
on me at any given time I've got so much
of that ammo I am low on this ammo I
could do it some more I never like to be
to without
okay I know I have a lot of the other
ammo so I'll switch to the gun for a bit
I'm not happy about it
not happy about it
all right let's do this
I don't think that there was another
wait a minute wasn't there
my brain is tickling me
there's another yeah over here oh
my God
I see
ah
appusal well good thing I was paying
attention to that
anybody
interesting
money
I like money
well that wasn't a whole lot of goodies
but it was something at least
all right we are on the way now
going to the end
good for me good for us good for
everybody involved
well I say the end we're only like
halfway through the game a little more
than half a little more
foreign
hey what's up
[Music]
don't waste that on you
uh-huh
you want to say that to my face whoa
don't say it to my face
[Applause]
uh-huh okay I like shaving
okay
so
lots of grownies lots of Monies lots of
moan groans and grown moans
all the in-betweens
where did I see I saw on the dis oh in
there ah
ah man I really got to pay attention
more
please tell me that's not something huge
stomping its way towards me
you're good ah I like nodes
oh God I should have bought some more
nodes I only have the one and I got the
money
at least I have level three yes yes
thank you yes
who's screaming out there God get over
it
thank you all right moving back to the
elevator
changing floors
Getting Gone
miss this more rounds
more beautiful bullets
okay looks pretty good
why oh hey what are you doing over there
what are you doing what what are you
doing look at this guy what are you
doing
what are you doing grumpy
take this
there's got to be another one over here
right
there you go
all right watch out for those elevator
doors there doozy all right down to
maintenance
okay
I got a funny feeling I'm gonna have
some visitors on this elevator
oh God
make it stop
it stop what
oh
that was the marker
did you no
I didn't see anything
I love him and Samuel again
just
get that so I'm speaking
I went off this [__] ship
this is peculiar
this is very very peculiar
oh boy
why is the marker on the ship
what's going on over there I have a
funny feeling I know what's gonna happen
as soon as I look around this corner
oh God
who's moaning who's burning up yep I
know those sounds
I know what you're doing over there hey
stop that
hey stop that oh I can detonate that
remotely really
whoa
slay off him
lay up lay up we'll lay off me
off me reload please Quick Pass love
that
oh boy oh whoa whoa who wants a limb
you better watch out I got a limb
okay I don't uh uh where are okay
oh hey pal
oh my God can I please just where is it
ah
oh there you are oh God
in there one more
oh did that kill you
hell yeah
I'm a badass oh hell yeah
man I don't know if they did too good a
job of keeping things out of these lower
levels
Oh weird
no there's no joke this is Secure
Storage okay so circuit power
only got one
start at four
well that's not where I was thinking it
would be oh Forbes four is no more uh
let's just assume four is uh with the
floor uh we we don't need four how about
three I like three
three's good well oh my God oh my God
three ain't for me three is not for me
three we don't like three
three will let me how about two
I like two
I knew it two's good
record then
what difference does it make now Karen I
know the marker is responsible for the
outbreak I need to understand how
signal when it pulses that signal can
trigger alterations in genetic code
neural structure even
you felt it haven't you but how do I
stop it
we're so much snow
taking all his marker research research
up to his room on the crew deck and seal
no no feel this
do you know how
please I need Mercer's data no he'll
kill you I won't have more deaths on my
conscience unitology was all I had after
I lost Amelia
look what it's come to Terence
I mean if it weren't for you I never
would have made it this far because you
made me stick with it
well just remember I'm giving you up for
six months so you can do this oh you
loved Amelia as much as I love Isaac but
if I can't cure this outbreak I'll never
see him again please help me
you must get into
that coach should still work
thank you 39277
paper with you
Dr Brennan
Nicole
the only thing Mercer ever feared was
death
now
I doubt he's afraid of anything
interesting
interesting so I found this Hideout well
I can't even get to the quarters 39277
[Music]
I'm so sorry Isaac look at the time
difference I'll I'll call you back later
it's okay
how you doing good
you were right Isaac the ishma is a
great ship I am so lucky to be serving
aboard her we'll enjoy a lot less you
know they're going to decommission her
next year
Isaac
thank you
for what
sorry just pushing me to do this I mean
if it weren't for you I never would have
made it this far because you made me
stick with it
well just remember I'm giving you love
for six months
[Music]
hello Nikki
I like one also wasn't that the oh no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no
get off me
demons
all right
well that went well
hey little shrimp dude
did I accidentally heal did I waste one
of my big man I really wish it wasn't
the F button but I think I had a small
one that must have been what that was I
tell myself with confidence but yeah
wasn't that the intro to Dead Space 2
well it makes sense oh
[Music]
wow
wow buddy in Repose in reports
oh well don't mind me you do your thing
I'll go the other way around
wow
oh really something special
that was really something
all right who else wants to mess with me
I don't like you
I throw something at you
uh I would but
hey shut up
yeah that's what I thought I'm still
gonna keep uh using the gun just because
I got the ammo for it might as well
save my
slicer and dicer for something other
oh this seems like some horrible
Gauntlet of some kind
wow slow
oh my God you got this is some kind of a
joke right this is a joke
oh what is that no
well not that I needed to do that okay
that was a bit excessive uh yeah
I need more of those explodies
no
more explodes please
I go
well I heard that I heard that there you
are okay missed
and Miss with that too all right missed
that as well
I'll never get that back okay well I
have this well this is going horribly
do they make it
for later oh
hi
hello
uh
hello oh my God I can't believe you're
here
hi
if I never see you again
I'm gonna get us home there's an SOS
Beacon nearby we can call for help the
beacon right
they locked it in the workshop but my
clearance can get us done this way
all right I'll just jump I'll jump
across the chasm
I'll jump
oh I'll jump
oh I can definitely make this jump
there's so much I need to tell you
I know we'll have time I promise let's
get you that Beacon everyone's counting
on us
you know if you make a running leap I
think you can make it
I'll save you
oh
hey stay away from her
stay away from me
[Music]
well that was easy the workshop's open
I've never seen you at work
you're a surgeon with that thing thank
you
okay
how do I reach you no focus on launching
that SOS Beacon there's maintenance
ducts everywhere I'll catch up
okie dokie then
more you hide okay cross my heart I love
you Isaac you can do this
thank you things back the way they were
and make us whole again
that's a funny phrase anyway fighting
all right cool
well I'll see you around soon
yeah I love that woman hey you ever seen
a woman like that but not silly
interesting
Korea
through here okay
hello anybody Here God I just getting
Getty with excitement
what a gal
what a gal you know
can't wait to make a soul again I can't
believe she said that right out loud or
anyone could do
oh anyway
oops God dang it and that time I did use
it probably a big one oops
that's okay it's okay who cares when
you're in love
schematics
suit upgrade yes please
am I going this way oh I gotta launch it
okay
Nicole's there
separated she'll find her way back she's
a trooper huh I'm heading back to the
mining control room I'll launch the
beacon you watch out for Nicole assuming
the system doesn't fizzle out again stay
sharp why stop it stop I know you were
just napping but you gotta stop that
you're not allowed
okie dokie then oh what's all this
hey wait wait a minute hey
hey I don't take kindly to that
I don't appreciate that none at all what
am I dropping down there weird all right
let me see this
okay uh
uh oh
well no more Gondola for me I guess
Oh weird I can go down here
oh no
oh no oh
okay something's going weird up there I
hear sounds
wow hey
hey I knew it I knew there was someone
there
I knew it
oh
I see a door I see a little silhouette
of a door
hey I hear you but I'm not gonna pay
whoa bulbous
didn't even get a chance
let me in please
thank you
weapon upgrade for what oh flamethrower
man who cares
oh
whoa no groaning you stop stop being
stop being
I see you down there
no God I use that I hate that that
that's that that that's button
I hate that that button
okay who needs Health anyway not me
fats attacks of cash
oh you go away
okay
a house stop it
where'd that even come from you
and who else you
ow
that really hurt Nicole I'm here
you looking at my gal
what's all this then
security recording system unit blibited
security recording system repair room
why can't I go in
whatever okay so there was some reason
for me to do all this
oh I need to go back
ah that would make sense
that does make sense all right I think
we're done here
unless let me check real quick to see I
think I already got the
the one here yeah chief engineer in
engineering Hydroponics maintenance and
communication so I don't have any of
those yet
that's okay I don't need them
thank you whoa my God okay that the
first one that's gotten me in a while
wow
[Applause]
all right
oh hey bud hey good to see you again you
just chilling you chilling all right far
bead for me to stop you you keep having
a good old time
what
don't mess with my bud
don't mess with my bro oh no no
how could you do that no well no
personals all right
whatever that means
but I did it
I win now I got the nope I go up to
Mining and I get this stuff taken care
of SOS Beacon out was that always broken
I feel like that wasn't broken before
not my fault
I wasn't here when it happened probably
there's no one with any evidence to the
otherwise
okay
of course there is
which ammo I'm running
uh yes time to switch
come on do it I dare you I buried the
door is that a baby
stop
another baby where what
what oh on the ground
holy crap
how did you get down there what is that
what is that
oh
where holy crap okay hi
take your own arm or whatever
you get
20 body parts whoa hey bud
[Applause]
all right
a lot of blades on the ground they are
hard to get after a while
sure
uh
okay can I get one of those yes just in
time
there's nothing goopy behind me no one
can prove anything
there is nothing goopy behind me
good great I get a suit upgrade and I
definitely won't be mangled horribly
definitely not
35 000 holy heck
worth it good thing I saved my money
yes please
questions
okie dokie so I have even more inventory
now I can sell this I need to take that
upgrade thing to a bench uh I'm actually
good on ammo I've got lots of contact
beam ammo I should start using that no I
want more nodes give me nodes
give me more nodes I want two more
because I just bought the thing I needed
and therefore I'll never need anything
else ever again
and I think there's a bench right over
here I'll save after the bench
uh thank you thank you now let's see
what this suit's got
k-i-doo
yes 1.1 I'll take it duration and then
HP ERG
I guess take that take that man what
would be up there
size
no one oh come on
get out of here who needs that
uh no I'll hold on to him
yes
very excited extremely happy
I'm very way I'm not happy
oh God
you guys are getting tougher I thought
my Kinesis throw damage was great I
threw a whole limb at you
I like saving all right and I think I go
back down here plan a okay so let's
begin
wrong way every time great
oh level three yes please
thank you
little eyes little eyes What secrets
have you seen I don't know
why would you say something like that
how would you ever even say words like
that holy crap
did I do that
okay goodbye
whoa no no baby
what how are you alive get stomped
that's what
that's what you get
all right
oh good it's this room that definitely
is not a showdown room launch tube load
Beacon
prepping launch tubes
buy what what was that the miners must
have booby trap the launch tubes too for
scrap well that's great we can't just
toss the beacon out a window yeah
there's gotta be something
the asteroid the one in the mining Bay
for smelting what about it if I attach
the SOS Beaker to that asteroid and then
launch it away from the ship we'd get a
clean broadcast and you've got yourself
killed the Machinery in there is still
running Isaac then it probably kept
those things out too this is our best
shot Kendra I'm taking it
yep okay I don't see how this could fail
all right let's do this apparently
I get to go plan to Beacon oh
oh
it's fine
okay hey what's up bud
what really
try me
Try Me if You Dare
don't try me
I'm out here you didn't get a chance to
try me you were too slow
all right
am I going over there
the mining Bay am I going to the mining
Bay I'm assuming I'm going to the mining
Bay that seems like we're yeah
yeah that's about right
okay
what
no what oh my God what oh no no no no no
none of that
oh God what
run ow
did you sneak up on me
how in the world did you sneak up on me
ow
ouch
yeah huge all right fine
you weirdos
no no no more of that
that's what you get
oh where's the power butt
anybody seen a powerbot around here
big old honking power butt
uh there was one in the other room over
there
let's take that one
that's a power butt
I got it
I won't have any horrible consequences I
bet uh yeah
[Music]
hey hey
where'd it go come on oh you just died
you fell over and died
all right
well that made it a lot easier
um
okay
wham bam I'm so wow that's a lot of
goodies that's a lot of Stacy specs that
seems weirdly specific
hmm
yeah an odd thing to give me so many
stasis packs all in one go but uh I'm
not gonna
I'm not gonna turn up my nose to that
anybody well there's a stasis machine
right here
I know
thank you for that thank you for that
can I just can I rip the thing off there
we go
big old spiky do
okay
there's no emergency shutdown I have to
disabled it the hard way let the SOS
vegan on the cell
okay
I mean it doesn't have to work I could
always die in a horrible industrial
accident related death
well you know how it is well
what was that
okay that's just the thing okay let me
see this
okay well we're not gonna let me do that
oh
each other disengaged well much easier
than I thought
oh wow
you seem tougher
why are you tougher
oh boy
oh oh where there you are
I'll marry you
well you're not tougher you're not
tougher at all
you're not tougher at all or I was
worried for a second
all right there's another gravity tether
up tippy toppity
[Music]
exterior tethers huh
damn those are big and squonky
can I just slip my excuse me
oh wow
I bet there's some Secrets out here but
also am I gonna be able to get any air
anywhere
that's kind of my main concern
excuse me ah O2 and stasis wow that's
handy
together
what is a what is a whispery
wushy sounds
oh God
there's bound to be some goodies around
here somewhere
good morning
I just ran into the damn thing
immediately uh have you stopped shaving
it
okay I assume you stopped shaving it I'm
just assuming
so do I just plant it on it
where
you never know where you are
maybe I gotta put it on the outside or
do I just land on it
hey
oh it's glowing
ah that is really specific
oh cool
bacon
I did it
whoa babies how are you crawling on that
how are you doing that
can you stop
where'd you go
all right one second come here come here
come here come here come here come here
come here come here there we go
all right where are we
where's down is that down that's down
oh God
oh my God and land
okay I think that's all I needed to do
now I just go back up into the other
room and slam bam Wham I'm in business
[Music]
hey
that's right were you shy
wait come back wait come back
where'd you go
what what
where did you go
coward
oh you scared
you're too scared of me
oh I'm sorry
didn't realize I was dealing with a
coward oh my God
okay
this uh
all right
nope I missed my chance
just gonna whoosh
probably save for it
okay we're good well that was
inconvenient
oh whoa anyone got it anyone want to be
wonked with a giant battery
here it's really good for you
hello
you're doing that yeah I keep doing that
oh no not there
oh hi baby
what are you doing there baby
yeah yeah oh oh God damn it oh I just
got us that would have been perfect
what what damn you baby damn you
all right whatever oh I can actually I
forgot to open these
thank you more stasis packs that's
suspicious
just gonna say it's suspicious wait a
minute
oh okay I'm in the right spot launch
wow it's working
the beacons online broadcasting White
Band I'll align the receiver
this will take a minute
head on back to the train station okay
oh I lose it
I knews use it
what
whoa
hi big guy um listen I didn't expect you
I was like look I was sassing you really
hard
door release I'll try
uh keep trying
I'm holding it because this is why they
gave me so many stasis backs I Now
understand
where are you yeah
whoa whoa hey whoa there's no need it's
ready
oh here we go
good
ow
ens
I'm going
well hey what are you doing here
[Music]
there you go
reloadive reloading reloading reloading
reloading go Downy go Downy
reloady okay
oh I'm not even gonna have a chance to
hit the shop
I like saving I like saving I like
saving I like saving I like saving I
like saving I like saving I like saving
I like saving
you think I got time for a little
shopping
do you think uh you think anyone would
mind if I just hit the store for a
little bit
ah you know I always need a little time
for me
yeah we gotta
gotta shop you know until I drop who
needs this many stasis packs not me
maybe I'll hold on to one two
maybe I'll get some more ammo
I mean
that doesn't sound good okie dokie
goodbye
okay goodbye
oh no
oh if only I hadn't gotten rid of all
the traps oh my God hi what's up
is it not automatically using a Oh I
thought it would automatically use a
stasis when I was
oh my God
okay please sit down thank you I'm gonna
get in this elevator all right there
were items on the ground but I wow hey
whoa whoa whoa whoa don't get in here
with me they were going up
that's what you get that's what you
deserve
that's what you deserve okay I'm gonna
actually I need to use this real quick I
think it's gone but I can't be sure
no [__] that again
I'm giving those camera glitches the
ones that look like my brother waving at
me
at least the beacons away
I'm aligning the wait
a rave receiver not responding
oh [__] The Columns are right we never
fixed it because it wasn't a broken
encoder then let's hope that 48 Hours
estimate was wrong too no calms no
rescue
take the tram to the bridge I'll hack
open the door to Communications you see
what's happening with the array
and don't worry about Nicole
like Kevin said
she'll do the smart thing
uh-huh did Hammond say that I don't I
don't actually remember anything
no
wait a minute I like saving there's a
PS4 time for this
oh boy oh my God stop
you dead
oh my God oh my God oh my God oh my God
stop
where are you
okay
good
okay I'm stocked up
not doing the best on health but you
know I've got some
I'm getting the hell out of here mining
was
just a nightmare
mining is not good for anybody's health
I got one of those things and I'm happy
about that
I need two more or three more big big
big big big codes
and then I'll get everything I need
it was probably like a level three
security door on um
anywhere else but I missed it so I
didn't see it
but oh
well that
is the end of that thank you everybody
so much for watching
hope you're enjoying dead space that was
a particularly stressful one but I made
it through will I make it to the end
probably but we'll see you never really
know what these things thank you as
always I will see you in the next video
bye-bye